inside Justin Timberlake Super Bowl
halftime show et is in Minneapolis with
JT for all the action
happy Friday my friends Justin
Timberlake is just two days from his
first solo Super Bowl halftime show is
it weird that I don't watch football but
I love the Super Bowl in any case you
know whatever justin has plan is going
to be pretty epic because that's what
you do on the world's biggest stage and
et is on the ground in Minneapolis with
the man of the woods himself how's
everyone doing sound like y'all need a
little more coffee like how is everybody
doing that's okay
I need that energy on Sunday how's this
for sexy a Super Bowl bromance is
brewing between Justin and Patriots
quarterback Tom Brady who's my man crush
got tough questions Jesse said like I
like Justin a lot too I made the list
I'd say he's on my list the feeling is
reciprocated if you want to make this
official
I don't know if the verdict is out on
his dance moves so he has great hair
though I mean great hair don't worry
guys during Thursday's press conference
in Minnesota Justin said Jimmy Fallon
who will pre tape an introduction Sunday
will always be his number one well I
think all of you know that I'm telling
the truth when I say nothing could ever
come between Jimmy and I but for fans
holding out for that in secret Union on
stage Sunday
well it looks unlikely no no to be
honest I had a ton of grand ideas about
special guests from NSYNC - to Jay to
Chris Stapleton to Janet and but this
year I'm just excited my band is the
Tennessee kids that I feel like those
they're my special guests and I'm
excited this year to uh to to rock the
stage so it's it's gonna be a lot of fun
now for context Katy Perry had the
most-watched halftime show ever with
120 plus million viewers in 2015
Beyonce and her reunion with Destiny's
Child in 2013 set the record for tweets
with 268 thousand per minute so a lot of
eyes will be on Justin to see what
surprises he has up his sleeve in the
meantime Timberlake just dropped two the
new album man of the woods is out today
and I want to know which tracks are you
guys bumping this weekend what are your
favorites let me know but it is Friday
which means there are some other new
jams we got to talk about churches one
of my favorite bands is back with their
latest single get out take a listen
[Music]
attention
Kelly
lead singer Lauren Mayberry says their
new Alpi is the most pop stuff they've
ever done so gear up for some bops
and you know who else has returned with
some new stuff Iggy Azalea lover or hang
her she's back with senior
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thoughts commentary has cardi B stole in
her career let me know what you guys
think of the new trap and finally here's
your new favorite banger for the weekend
thanks to steve aoki petrie daddy yankee
[Music]
there you guys have it new music Friday
lit as always now go enjoy your weekend
and your Super Bowl Sunday whether
you're watching the game Justin
Timberlake or the commercials I hope
your snacks are as good as mine